Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Naomi, Tomás, Sarah, Dana. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Before the main topic, let's do a fast round — where's everyone at? Keep it short.
I've been heads-down on the label renderer and the validator tests. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
the manifest schema and validator — steady. One open question I'll raise when we get to it, otherwise fine.
I've been heads-down on the security review pipeline. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
On my side, the CARE governance framework is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the security review pipeline.
Good point — let's do that.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Sure, I can own that.
How does this interact with the manifest schema and validator, if at all?
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
On my side, the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Good point — let's do that.
Okay, works for me.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Good point — let's do that.
Makes sense to me.
This one's short. I introduced a regression in the label renderer this morning, noticed the test go red, and posted in #incidents within the hour instead of hiding it. Fixed by lunch with the new reviewer.
For the record from my side: Ben pinged me the moment the test went red, which is exactly what I asked him for back in April. The fast disclosure is the system working.
Wait — before you move on, can you go back one slide?
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Good point — let's do that.
Sure — one sec.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Just flagging that this touches the security review pipeline, so loop me in when it firms up.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Makes sense to me.
Right, that's what I meant.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Makes sense to me.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Sure, I can own that.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Good point — let's do that.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Good point — let's do that.
Let's confirm in the channel.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the label renderer and the validator tests anyway.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the label renderer and the validator tests.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
That's fair.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the label renderer and the validator tests.
Makes sense to me.
Time-to-surface was under an hour. In Q2 the comparable one took four days. That's the whole difference.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the label renderer and the validator tests anyway.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
That's fair.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Fair.
How does this interact with the security review pipeline, if at all?
Agreed, let's capture it.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the security review pipeline.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
And nobody had to talk Ben into saying it. Ben, a quarter ago this exact situation cost us four days of silence. What changed?
Fair.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Okay, works for me.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Agreed, let's capture it.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
That's fair.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Alright, moving on.
It's just normal now to say it. The retro culture and the 1:1 with Dana — I stopped thinking a mistake meant I didn't belong.
That's the andon cord working. Nothing to fix here, this is the win. Blameless note's already filed.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Hang on, let me pull that doc up on my end. One sec.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Let's confirm in the channel.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Yeah, exactly.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Right, that's what I meant.
How does this interact with the label renderer and the validator tests, if at all?
That's fair.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Right, that's what I meant.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Sure, I can own that.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Sure — one sec.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Should I loop anyone else in on the the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync side, or is that covered?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Should I loop anyone else in on the the manifest schema and validator side, or is that covered?
One thing: how does this affect the the CARE governance framework timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Ben has the follow-up on the label renderer and the validator tests — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Naomi has the follow-up on the manifest schema and validator — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Tomás has the follow-up on the security review pipeline — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.